Narcissism is a serious personality disorder
that has many damaging effects.
It seems like common sense to stay away from
those who exhibit excessive selfish behavior,
but what if they're your own parents?
Here are Seven Subtle Signs of Narcissistic
Parenting.
Number one: They're self-centered and make
you join the show too.
Everyone is self-cautious and cares to a certain
degree what other people think about them,
that's human nature.
But do you ever wonder why your parents act
so differently at home than they're out in
public?
Even for narcissist, their slips and the mask
comes off.
Narcissistic parents take pride in flaunting
their social status, physical appearance,
material possessions and accomplishments.
But when they no longer have an audience once
they pull up in the driveway, they stop with
the nice act. They either criticize or talk
about others behind their back.
Number two: You can't receive gifts without
feeling like there're strings attached.
Giving presents is supposed to be a selfless
deed.
It's about celebrating the other person's
who's receiving the gift; whether it's on
their birthday, graduation or just because.
So why does it feel like there are consequences
when you receive one from a narcissist?
The narcissistic parent knows how to guilt
trip you if you don't love or use their gift.
And when it comes to buying presents for them,
forget having to brainstorm, they usually
tell you or demand for what they want in return.
Number three: When you try to set boundaries,
they get offensive.
If there's one thing a narcissistic parent
loves is control.
Why?
Because treating the child like an equal would
mean they aren't superior or above them.
If you live with a narcissistic parent, some
of these might sound familiar; they go through
your room without your permission and throw
away some of your possessions.
They dictate your extracurricular activities
or classes you can take and they set unrealistic
expectations on you without hearing what you
have to say first.
But when you do stand up for yourself, they
get easily hurt or are offensive and use excuses
like; it was just spring cleaning or I’m
just doing what's best for you.
Number four: You feel like you're their puppet
more than you are their child.
Dress-up and make-believe is fun as a kid,
but narcissistic mothers take that to a whole
‘nother serious level.
Patients of narcissistic parents were interviewed
by psychologists and one of them said her
mom used to love dolling her up in cute dresses
even though she was a tomboy by nature.
She believe that [?] her mom's
self-worth when she will receive compliments
for her parents.
Under eyes of a narcissistic parent, the child
acts as a medium they can live through.
This is how the child's individuality becomes
diminished, replacing it with their own selfish
desires.
Number five: They feel hurt when you don't
include them in your decisions.
Psychotherapist Daniel Sobel says that a narcissistic
parent operates from self-protection, and
if the ego is bruised or they feel the decision
was made they could not control, they become
cruel, blaming and offensive.
A healthy parent decides how many sweets their
child can have after dinner but a narcissistic
parent will want to govern everything; what
kind of career you can have, who you can date
and when you can move out.
Nothing scares them more than when we start
thinking for yourself and no longer need their
validation.
Number six: You feel like you can't make good
decisions without them.
Narcissistic parenting creates a codependent
relationship between the parent and child.
This can make the child anxious and feel lost
without the parents help.
But that's exactly what they want.
Often, the child will grow feeling confused
and invalidated when their thoughts and feelings
were ignored.
Often, the child will grow up feeling confused
and invalidated when their thoughts and feelings
were ignored.
Although going through puberty is already
a dizzying experience, a narcissistic parent
will make sure to tear down your self-identity
too, leaving you feeling more helpless than
ever.
By doing this, they make me depend on them
to feel your own self-worth.
Number seven: They know how to turn the table
and play the victim.
No matter how reasonable or logical your argument
is, the narcissistic parent will find a way
to manipulate you and point fingers.
Narcissists never take responsibility for
their actions and marginalize your needs and
feelings.
This is how they play mind games with you,
but they get off easy because they play their
victim card well.
Not anymore though, now that you know about
these signs, you no longer have to participate
in the cruelty.
We hope this video was helpful.
Do you struggle with narcissistic parents?
We also made a video on 16 just effects of
narcissistic parenting.
Please be sure to check it out.
Hey Psych2Go fans! Just a short announcement
here.
As many of you may have noticed, YouTube has
added a membership button.
And what better way to get involved than to
add it to our channel?
You can now become an exclusive member to
our channel.
You'll get custom emojis and a bash beside
your name.
Not only that, you'll get a free eBook every
month and a hard copy every quarter.
This membership is about adding more to your
channel and showing love to your fans.
We will still be posting videos two times
a week and keeping psychology up to date.
So, please make sure to check it out.
Thank you!